hey i'm here with this guy what do you  think about the news today  all news is sad news today  cam newton he's always throwing that  ball around and kicking it up and down  the court what do you think about the  next prospect for the year  first it's not court it's field he plays  football not basketball just fyi you  look like obama  i'll take it  i will take it first black i'll take it  what is your favorite obama quote  don't quit because he's right once if  you never quit you can make it and be  anything  [Music]  do you think obama ever said the n-word  of course he's black yes  all black people have said it at some  point i'm just a black guy you see me  just haul at me